language is a human universal
every people every culture has developed
its own language
in fact there are over 6 000 languages
in use today and historically there have
been many many more
but written language the written word
was not developed everywhere
independently
while there are thousands of spoken
languages there are only a few hundred
writing systems and only a handful of
those writing systems are widely and or
often used
the most widespread of these systems is
the latin alphabet it's seen throughout
western europe the americas australia
southern africa turkey and more it is
also the base of our own english
alphabet but where did the alphabet come
from how has it changed over time and
why is it so widespread today
[Music]
our story starts with one of the oldest
civilizations in the world
egypt
egypt had a complicated and
sophisticated system of writing that we
now know as hieroglyphics hieroglyphs
were pictograms
small drawings that represent objects
animals and concepts this type of
writing system is called a logographic
system
so how did this complicated system of
over 700 pictograms condense into the
alphabet we know today
well it took a lot of time in around the
16th or 17th century bc egypt had grown
its empire far outside the river nile
and into libya down to ethiopia and most
importantly for our story up into asia
specifically to the land of canaan
the local canaanites would not normally
have been taught the full egyptian
script which was mostly used by priests
and scribes
that being said some canaanites somehow
or another were able to take many of the
hieroglyphs and fit them into their own
language
they took some of the common characters
simplified them and gave them each a
sound the sounds corresponded to the
pictograms based on their meaning for
example the character per which in
hieroglyphics meant house
was given the sound
for the canaanite word for house
baitu this alphabet has now come to be
known as the proto-cynic alphabet named
for the sinai peninsula where many of
the surviving records of the script have
been found
once the egyptian empire receded in the
12th century bc the canaanites or by
this point more commonly called
phoenicians quickly became the most
dominant trading power in the
mediterranean they built an extensive
maritime network from north africa egypt
italy and most importantly for our story
greece
by this point the proto-cynic alphabet
evolved into the phoenician alphabet it
greatly simplified the pictograms used
by the egyptians into almost completely
abstract symbols a few of which you may
recognize the phoenician trading network
transferred many things both material
and immaterial around the mediterranean
one such thing was their alphabet the
phoenician alphabet was copied by many
groups of people the arameans in syria
the hebrews in palestine and the greeks
in greece
according to the greek historian
herodotus the alphabet was brought to
greece by a phoenician prince named
kadmos he was also an important greek
hero of the likes of heracles and
perseus he was certainly a legendary
figure though and not a historical one
as you can see the archaic greek
alphabet is quite similar to the
phoenician one but the letters have
evolved and a few more were added
the most important innovation the greeks
made was the addition of vowels you see
the previous alphabets were not true
alphabets but abjads
abjads are writing systems similar to
alphabets in that each letter represents
one sound but an abjad does not include
vowels
instead the vowels are implied through
context modern abjads include hebrew and
arabic the greeks took letters in the
phoenician alphabet that they had no use
for and substituted them for vowel
sounds for example the letter alep which
represented a glottal stop a sound not
used in greek became alpha which made
the ah sound
the archaic greek alphabet had two main
variants
an eastern variant and a western one the
eastern script was used in athens and it
evolved into the modern greek alphabet
as well as the cyrillic alphabet used in
much of eastern europe
the western greek alphabet was used in
the western greek colonies you see in
the 8th century bc
some of the greek city-states learning
from their phoenician neighbors created
colonies throughout the mediterranean
the eubans who used the western alphabet
created colonies in southern italy and
this is where the greek alphabet was
spread to the etruscans
the etruscans were the dominant italian
civilization before the rise of rome
their alphabet was very similar to the
western greek but they dropped some of
the letters they had no use for
by the 7th century bc the romans had
interacted with the etruscans enough
that they adopted their alphabet over
time it became the latin alphabet that
we know and love
as you can see they added the letters y
and z to the end
this happened around the time alexander
the great was conquering the persian
empire yep the romans were around at the
same time as alexander history overlaps
itself sometimes
the final form of the latin alphabet was
formalized during the roman empire the
roman language latin was spread
throughout western europe eventually
even areas where latin wasn't spoken
like the german lands scandinavia and
the british isles adopted their script
replacing their previous runic alphabets
the anglo-saxons adopted the latin
alphabet for old english around the time
they were christianized
the english alphabet actually has its
own history as you can see the latin
alphabet doesn't include everything we
do
for one it's all capital letters as
romans didn't have a use for lowercase
also the letters j u and w are all
missing this separate history will have
to wait for another time however in the
17th and 18th centuries many of the
european powers started exploring and
eventually colonized much of the world
these new empires spread their languages
and cultures to far-off places in the
americas the most widely spoken
languages are all western european in
africa english and french are very
widely spoken and so on and so forth
with this language spread the latin
alphabet of course spread as well
even many non-european languages now use
the latin alphabet like swahili and east
africa and tagalig in the philippines
even in countries where the latin
alphabet isn't used school children will
often be taught the alphabet because of
how widespread it is
so that's the history of the latin
alphabet in a later video i plan to
explore the ways the english alphabet
evolved after the latin script was
brought to english shores but until then
thank you so much for watching please
leave the video a like share it with a
friend subscribe if you haven't already
and hit the bell icon to be notified
whenever i upload a new video
bye
[Music]